you know but you know I honestly I've
been thinking about you a lot and I just
want you to I know that you you're
thinking that you're strong as an ox and
I know that but I just I worry that I
don't want you to go out and think that
you can beat I just don't want you to
catch this thing I'm going to be mindful
and careful and be aware of your to
somebody for actions because we don't
leave the house at all especially this
week this is the week two if you can
order your groceries and medicine
because I think it's they expect the
next two weeks to be really dicey oh I'm
good I'm stocked up I don't plan on me I
don't let you leave anyway yeah leave
when I really need to like when you know
like I'll go to I'll go to get my
nicotine pouches every two and a half
weeks or something yeah let me ask you
some do to your neighbors do you hang
out with them or no no I don't see
anyone dude you know even Greg you don't
see him you don't see crap look Craig
doesn't go and Craig only goes to his
parents and back home even with his
parents we don't know where he's been no
no no he's been very very very very
careful if anything Craig's the one that
got me the legit face mask I got oxygen
I got an oxygen tank okay that that's a
very flammable thing like if it's good
it's sitting next to the Golden Grahams
it's fine okay good torpedo I got paper
towel I'm good I'm good sometimes can I
have confessed yeah times I wake up and
it's 8 p.m.
wake up cuz I not only that because I in
a sense I love it because it's the
excuse it's like well this coronavirus I
could sleep whatever I want you were
doing that before the quarantine not a
p.m. okay let me ask you this or let be
honest with me no have I called you at 6
p.m. and you've been
you just woke up on are my life let me
ask you yeah sometimes I love it
I love waking up and then taking the
earbuds up off out yeah yeah I don't
know where I am
you love it I love it it's like one of
my favorite things in the world yeah I
do like kind of sleepy I love sleeping
12 hours of sleep it's the best yeah cuz
before it's like you know like you know
I feel bad because you know I Lani's on
a normal schedule and it's like I would
feel guilty but now it's like since this
quarantine thing and this Korona thing
I'm like well you know I can't leave
anyway yeah I love it you can play all
oh yeah I love I think that's a good
survival strategy just full hibernation
hibernation Stiles like wake up defrost
yourself in September yeah not only that
I still get my work done though like I'm
editing I'm you know what I mean yeah do
that because before I would have to like
kind of divide that time you know
sometimes I'd go to walnut you know for
the weekend so I have to do certain but
now I'm like yeah I love it we are going
to take a quick break to talk about one
of our oldest and most favorite sponsors
[Music]